host for today's webinar Rasha Khan here
joining all the way from Bangalore India
and you can drop us a hello on the chat
and let us know where are you tuning in
from also please don't forget to mention
your name sometimes it's very hard to
make out your name from your email IDs
so I see folks have already started
saying a quick uh highs and Hells uh on
the chat here so good evening
everyone and uh we're just doing quick
round of introductions on the chat here
before we start thank you for joining in
early my name is Rasha Khan and I'm your
host for today's webinar and uh we'll be
going through the program review of I
gu's Cloud plus devops uh program before
that we would just have a quick CR of
introductions on the chat here let's get
to know each other right let's introduce
ourselves on the chat it's always good
to network these events before we start
so as I can see
folks have started ining themselves on
the chat here so I can see Muhammad Yas
has joined from Pune so hi hi good
evening good evening everyone I see a
lot of hellos coming in on the chat here
so that's
great
I see more introductions coming in on
chat in few minutes right on time
we'll be doing a program preview of the
I ghati Cloud plus devops program here
and also talking about carers uh in
cloud and devops in 2024 as
well job and sees that uh is working as
a junior associate Cloud infrastructure
so that's great good to have you
here and I see uh someone uh joining
from Nigeria as well so uh once again
welcome everyone we'll be starting the
session right on time uh we are just
doing a quick round of introductions
here before we start so it's fantastic
to have you all on board I'm Rashia Khan
and I'm I'm joining all the way from
Bangalore India and I'm thrilled to be a
host today you can drop us a hello on
the chat and let us know your name and
where are you tuning in from so before
we get started so we're just doing a
little bit of networking before we start
so we would love to know a little bit
about you before we
start
for today's webinar and we'll be
starting the session in few
minutes hey nvj I see navjot has joined
us from Assam I see Johnny has joined
from USA United States and a lot more
introductions coming in on chat here
that's great please uh keep uh the
introductions coming in and we'll be
starting the session right on time in
few minutes today's program preview is
for IAT goar Cloud plus devops program
and uh we are not just going to do the
program preview we'll be talking about
uh careers in in 2024 in cloud and
devops as
well
awesome I can see Coman has joined from
South
Africa and I can see Mohammad Yas has
joined us from Pune I can see a lot of
hellos different countries so that's
great we'll be starting the session uh
in few minutes Meanwhile we're just
doing quick round of introductions on
the chat
here
okay I can see uh PF also has given
introduction on chat uh basically uh
currently uh in first year of my
undergrad and uh should I attend a
session so why not welcome someone who's
studying also is completely welcome uh
this definitely will give you an idea
about where you can basically take your
career uh in basically in cloud and
devops right we'll be talking about
skills and career paths as well and as
I'm speaking we already have speaker
here with us so before we start let me
just quickly take you through the ground
rules of the session here so we have
quick easy ground rules in the session
so in case you have any questions for
our speaker Dr purushotam here today
who's already joined us you can put on
your questions in the Q&A box and uh the
session is being recorded in case you
want to go through the recording of the
session again in case you have missed
something you can expect a followup
email with the recording link and a
separate email for webinar certificate
as well so now for the webinar
certificate uh you need to make sure
that you basically put down your full
name in the post webinar survey of Zoom
so the post webinar survey basically
basically will be visible once we end
the session and uh it will basically uh
pop up in front of you if you have
joined from your mobile or laptop or
xtop and in that post webinar survey
there will be a space for full name and
you can put down your full name uh which
you would like want to see in the
webinar certificate and
Al
on let's talk about the agenda of
today's session so agenda of today's
session uh is basically getting to know
a little bit about you and how we can
help you out better in your career and
also uh we'll be talking about uh cloud
and devops career in
2024 and we'll be taking through the
program introduction of it bha's Cloud
PL devops
program
hi RHA am I
audible but just in case we are not able
to take your questions immediately
please don't worry just have some
patience and we'll try to take it
towards the end in the Q&A part of the
session so uh just make sure that your
questions are related to Cloud plus
devops career in general or this program
so that's
all and as I'm speaking we already have
gotten a question in the Q&A so that's
great uh so before we start as I
mentioned will'll be getting to know you
a little better so let me just quickly
launch a quick poll here which says that
how many years of experience do you
currently have so uh this way we'll get
to know uh folks who have joined us
basically come from different different
T set of experiences and that's make the
that makes the session pretty
interesting actually so uh you can see a
quick pull on your screen here which
says how many years of experience do you
currently have uh now when I talk about
experience here I'm talking about work
experience so uh let me just quickly
read out those options for you the first
one currently studying and second one 3
to 0 to 3 years third one 3 to 5 years
and the last one more than five
years so as we speaking I see folks who
have joined us are pretty active they
have already started sharing the
responses on the poll here so that's
great and uh for someone who basically
has no experience they can basically
select Z the of experience or can let us
know in the chat or in the Q&A box so
that's totally okay so I
think uh let's quickly uh go through the
chart here and also the Q&A as we have
started getting a lot of questions here
and if you have any other queries or
relating to webinars you can basically
let us know in the Q&A box I'm so sorry
we might miss the conversations on the
chart
here
quickly end the poll in 5 seconds so
last 5 seconds for for the poll five 4 3
2 1 let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you
folks so as we can see that uh 38% of
the folks who have joined us are
currently studying and 30% of the folks
who have joined us have Zer to three
years of experience and uh 27% of the
folks F who have joined us have more
than five years of experience and 6% of
the folks who have joined us have three
to five years of experience so thank you
so much for sharing that with us as you
can see that folks who have joined us
have different different set of
experiences and that makes the session
equally interesting uh before we move on
uh just for a lot of new folks who have
joined just to let you know that we just
quickly went through the ground rules
here where basically uh I mentioned that
if you have any questions for our
speaker today uh please go and put down
your questions in the Q&A box and we'll
be taking those questions throughout the
session whenever we get the time in case
we're not able to answer your queries
please don't worry this
have world's number one online boot camp
uh we have been in the little space uh
for almost 13 years now and we are very
proud that we have transformed lives by
empowering people people V digital
skills uh we have advanced over 5 lakh
plus careers uh we have categories of
courses comprising from
AI
uh if you're speaking we not able to
hear you uh Dr
Bram yeah I am I audible now yeah you're
audible uh just not okay okay visible
now awesome awesome welcome uh good
evening Dr purushotam it's always a
pleasure to have you and especially host
your sessions and also uh we would love
to know a little bit about you your
introduction for the folks who have
joined us here yeah yeah sure thank you
Rasha so hello everyone very good
evening to all of you and good morning
and good afternoon to others those who
are in different time zones yeah so my
name is Dr purushotam asani and I'm
working as an assistant professor in
Department of information and Technology
um Shri Ram College of engineering and
management nagpur um I've done uh my
research in a resource scheduling in
cloud and cloud computing um my PhD in
computer science and engineering from
vit Valor uh I specialize um in cloud
computing um in public Cloud platforms
that is Microsoft Azure AWS distributed
systems operating systems uh F Computing
and I'm a Microsoft certified trainer
AWS certified trainer AWS certified
Solutions architect professional which
is the top level certification in the
architect domain on AWS aw certified
Solutions architect associate aw
certified practitioner Microsoft Azure
administrator associate
uh Google Cloud professional
um Oracle certified associate and uh
yeah I'm um I'm working as a Solutions
architect technology Enthusiast
consultant and trainer certified Cloud
professional I'm a Google Scholar yeah
this is in short about me thank you
thank you so much Dr Pam for
introduction it's always a pleasure to
have you and we have an interesting
session lined up uh today uh before we
start so uh let's
RHA your voice is not audible next year
yeah now it's audible am I am I audible
yeah yeah now you're audible just for a
second okay please do let me know if
there's a disturbance I will join back
again so I think let's start with the
hottest skills in the cloud uh Dev of
space in
uh yeah RHA yeah um do I need to uh yeah
yeah uh let's talk about the hottest
skills in the cloud plus Dev of space in
okay right uh
so yeah so these are the hottest skills
I would say in the cloud plus develop
space in 20124 so uh see the first of
all you should be I mean uh Cloud
providers selection so as far as the
cloud provider selection is concerned if
you if you talk about the public Cloud
platforms guys so AWS and Azure I would
say are the market leaders uh wherein uh
there's an organization called as
Gartner which rates the different Cloud
platforms so they they are continuously
marking AWS as the market leader in the
I magic quadrant from quite some years
uh plus Azure is just behind so if
you're thinking like uh any company that
moves towards the cloud so their first
choices are AWS and then gcp okay so um
while you're selecting the cloud
provider that you want to learn or your
company wants to get into so AWS Azure
gcp are the obvious choices to go ahead
correct and um yeah so they are the
hottest U uh I would say the uh
platforms that you can learn uh in 2024
okay uh then application migration of
course uh uh so migration um is an
integral part because if you move to
Cloud platform so you'll have to migrate
like from your on premisis to these
Cloud platforms so uh migration uh is of
at most importance right um I think uh
uh Rasha is just
disconnected so maybe we can just wait
for a minute let her join in and because
the presentation is also got
disconnected okay
so maybe I'll just message
her okay okay fine yeah she's facing
some internet issue she's she's just
joining back okay
uh fine otherwise I can just see if I
have that presentation I must also be
having it so if if I have that I can
also uh guys get into this and I mean I
can also start off with this with the
presentation Tech
here okay and uh yeah so just give me a
moment I am just opening up the
presentation
deck
[Music]
and then I'll just start with this
okay yeah uh I think I have opened it
up yeah I think I am good with
this yes okay so I'll just share my
screen and I will get you through this
so that um there's no issue right so
cloud provider uh then the uh what do
you call it as the web services and API
so guys of course uh
um the when when I talk about any of the
cloud platforms uh let's say AWS or aure
so uh well uh it's all about as the name
says Amazon web services so so web
services and apis are a hot thing then
performance testing Cloud workloads uh
Auto scaling so when you talk about
Cloud you talk about uh horizontal
scaling when I when I say Auto scaling
so I'll give you an example let's say
the sale days U with flip cart Amazon
during the sale days guys um the uh the
workload uh on their website increases
it shoots up correct so uh at that time
uh to cater to that additional workload
uh they'll have to provision more number
of service and they'll have to do it in
an automated fashion correct and uh so
as to cater to that additional load so
that their websites doesn't go goes down
when the load increases and of course uh
when the load decreases those new
servers will not be required so so so
they can be uh reduced as well they can
be automatically terminated as well so
that you don't have to pay for them when
not required okay so that they don't
have to pay for them when not required
so this can be done uh with something
called as um autoscaling correct
okay yeah so this can very well be done
with something called as autoscaling
then of course identity and access
management uh so with identity and
access management basically you can
create users in Cloud you can can assign
them roles uh the policies so that they
can use some Services the resources in
the cloud platform correct so that is
possible with identity and exess
Management Services so this is pretty
pretty much very useful for
administrator kind of a role then of
course uh Cloud migration and deployment
so when you are migrating to cloud from
your on premises so Cloud migration
becomes a very important field uh to get
into and of course multicloud deployment
so uh yeah thank you yes so multicloud
deployment as in uh like uh today is the
era of multic clouds guys so because see
I mean when you are thinking of some
company moving towards Cloud platform or
using the cloud services so more often
than not it will not be just one Cloud
platform they will often um use some
cloud services from from One Cloud
platform let's say from AWS and some
other cloud services from other Cloud
platform let's say as sure so today is
the era of multic clouds guys so when
you want to learn Cloud it is better to
learn multiple clouds because your
organization would not be just be using
one uh cloud service provider services
but multiple service provider services
so the U good choice to go with is to
learn AWS assur and then gcp I would say
okay uh then of course when you are into
cloud like you have whatever you have it
in your on premises Let It Be Your
databases your storage space and
everything you have it in the cloud
correct so uh then learning database
manag ment in cloud storage Services
becomes very important okay and um there
are there are solutions for relational
data base in Cloud platform no SQL
databases like in Microsoft Azure you
have got Ms uh Azure SQL for relational
databases in AWS it is the service
called as RDS relational database
Service uh for no SQL um Azure has got
Cosmos DB uh well well well AWS has got
uh this uh Dynamo DB then then uh you
have graph databases just like kind of
Facebook kind of a structure okay so
like you have naptune as the graph DB in
AWS so you have a lot of services which
supports all different kinds of data um
the databases okay all different kinds
of databases then of course storage
services so Cloud providers have got uh
the solution for any type of data like
Let It Be object based storage uh blog
based storage file share storage they
have got the services they have got the
solutions like in AWS you have got uh S3
simple storage service which is there
for storing object based data EBS
volumes elastic block storage for
storing block based data uh something
like you can install the virtual hard
disk files um on EBS volumes block based
storage plus you can have shared storage
among your different virtual machines in
the form of file storage which is
provided by EFS FSX storage in ews
similarly n sure you have got um uh blog
blobs for stud uring the object based
Data Page blobs for for for for for
Block based data and of course Azure
file shares for uh sheared storage as a
sheared storage then uh of course for
Disaster Recovery um see Disaster
Recovery becomes an integral part when
we talk about Cloud because uh the uh
very good advantage of cloud is that it
also supports uh Disaster Recovery as
well like uh it is useful in Dr for Dr
purpos is also um I'll give you an
example guys uh let's say God forbid if
there's a natural disaster in one of the
region and if the complete region goes
down so all the servers in that region
will go down so if you have your servers
replicated in another region so of
course during that time also um you can
have access to your servers from another
region so that's why guys U even if the
entire region Goes Down Still you can
have access to your data to your servers
um and that is possible with the help of
Disaster Recovery services in these
Cloud providers like in AWS there's a uh
service called
as cross region application in S3 which
supports that and ass sure you have got
uh Recovery Services vault as a service
which supports a disaster recovery thing
okay so that's there yeah so uh yeah
these are there so uh thank you so much
Dr Pam for taking through the hot skills
in cloud and Dev space in 2024 and I
hope I'm Audible a little bit of tech
issue in between so sorry for that no
problems yeah yeah so as we have talked
about the skills here let's talk about
the career paths as well right what are
the trending career paths in Cloud F
devops in 2024 as you can see there are
so many career paths folks can take up
but maybe uh where where they can start
is something maybe you can uh you know
maybe introduce them to these career
paths yeah so see I would say if you are
a no way in Cloud uh platform uh if
you're just beginning up and uh you just
want to to learn from the fundamentals
part so the first step is to uh learn
the fundamentals that is uh if you are
going with let's say AWS so study AWS
Cloud practitioner course okay if you're
going with Azure then go with Az 900
Azure um uh fundamentals okay uh and and
so so with these fundamental course you
will get a knowhow of different services
in Cloud platforms so you'll be like
jack off many services but master of
none I would say but then you will at
least come to know that okay what cloud
and then what are the different services
and and and by the time you complete
that you will also get a get an idea
that uh how much you are interested in
Cloud platforms and then which field you
are interested in and once you once you
are done with your fundamentals then um
based on your roles in your
organizations or your interest you can
go with uh the particular uh domain like
if you are working as an administrator
uh or if you are interested to work as
an admin uh then probably you can go
with let's say ews isops admin
certification or um if in Azure it would
be Azure administrator associate
a104 um well if you want to get into the
architect side of the things then you
can uh of course first go with the ssops
admin or uh Azure administrator and then
you can Target for Azure architect or
AWS architect associate okay
um then uh of course uh uh other than
that if you are let's say uh on the
development end uh if you are a
developer then you can go with developer
kind of a certification like AWS
developer associate or uh Azure uh uh
developer uh associate that is a at 204
okay um because Azure has got different
CES for different courses okay um and
then if you are on the devop side then
you can go with devops engineer course
correct so that is the point that once
you finish off with your fundamentals
then you can go as per your roles you
can select your certification if you're
on the devops side you can go with
devops engineer architect side you can
go with architect uh Cloud architect
correct uh and if you are into the data
part of the things if you are on the
database side then you can become a
cloud data engineer okay um so so so so
so that is how you should go with okay
and that's how you can proceed further
okay so whatever you are doing in your
on premises whether you are an architect
or you want to become an architect or a
developer or devops guy or a developer
as I said or uh just a cloud engineer so
so you can get into those roles by doing
those kind of certifications in um these
Cloud platforms okay and uh then if you
are a no way if you do a practitioner
first and maybe then ssops admin or
Azure administrator associate then you
can start off with the role of cloud
engineer initially in your organization
correct yeah uh those there are so many
career paths to take up in cloud devops
Dr totally agree uh we would love to
know from the folks who have joined us
here I'm pretty sure you're aspiring for
a cloud plus devops career you would
love to know as you can see so many
career paths here which basically be
demand in 2024 and Beyond we would love
to know which one are you aspiring for
which one basically are you already
working towards or basically something
you are aspiring for you can so see so
many career paths we have covered you
can let us know on the chat here we
would love to uh basically see what what
are your responses in the chat here and
also uh as we were basically talking
about the skills and career paths we are
getting a lot of questions on the Q&A
box and also on the chat as well uh chat
is something we might actually miss it
because due to high chat volume so uh
please do move your questions towards
the Q&A box and uh I see like s has
responded that I want to be a cloud data
engineer Moos Cas devops engineer in
2024 so that's good that's good uh we
would love to see more sponsors here uh
I can see James uh if
sorry not your name Emil Cesar I would
love to go for devops in Junior and
Verma I cannot see response okay fine I
think you love to know your basically
responses on what career paths are you
aspiring for towards 20 24 doesn't have
to be all the basically list which you
see on the screen I'm pretty sure
there's much more which you know um you
can basically discover in this
particular stream of cloud plus devops
but yeah keep the responses coming in I
see Cloud native developer and Cloud
architecture and multicloud specialist
so that's great I
think let's move on
what's Dev space as dram yeah can you
come again please your voice was my
voice is breaking yeah uh a bit okay let
me turn off again yeah uh is it audable
now yes yes yes yeah probably that will
help yeah yeah
yeah soot of
responses yeah as we are seeing a lot of
responses coming in on chat uh regarding
the career paths they can take up is it
audible yes yes yes it's audible
yeah yeah uh folks are responding on the
chat with the career path they would
like to take up uh but let's talk about
what's changing in the cloud plus Dev of
space
202 correct okay so uh see basically um
as I said that multicloud dominance it's
going to be there guys it's it has
already started because uh I mean you
cannot think of like I mean because this
is a competitive world I mean um you
cannot think of like one provider AWS is
the only one in the market and whosoever
will uh go and adopt the cloud platform
whichever organization would just use
AWS no that is not the case anymore okay
um it's like uh some Services the
organizations will use from some Cloud
platform some from some other Cloud
platform correct so basically the
organizations are into multic clouds and
they will get into multic clouds if they
are not into so uh multicloud dominance
would be there so widespread adoption of
multicloud strategies would be there and
of course when I say multicloud so um
more often than not it is the market
leaders they are the market leaders that
are going to be adopted by the
organization that are AWS assure and gcp
so so try to learn um at least to start
with um you should be the the first two
Cloud providers that I would suggest you
to go with and to learn our AWS and
Azure Cloud platform and then you can um
uh go and think of gcp as well correct
that's what my suggestion would
be
uh no problem Ria yeah okay uh then uh
Cloud native uh Revolution um of course
accelerated migration to Cloud uh Native
Technologies um it's it's it's there
because uh you can you can just uh if
you are if you are Cloud aware if you
are good into the cloud platforms then
you can uh migrate to the cloud native
Technologies uh Dave seops um maturation
um is uh also there so stronger
integration of security in devops
because see devops has been a hot field
uh but now is you will also see that
Dave seops is uh also gaining a lot of
Market because it's like providing
Security in devops the security that two
in devops is a good thing right so it is
catching up a lot yeah so that can be um
there uh a good space in 2024 correct
then AIML integration so artificial
intelligence machine learning are uh I
mean uh the more that you explore into
it uh it is uh you will feel like there
is a lot of things to be yet to be
explored correct so wider use of a IML
in Automation and monitoring it's going
to even increase more and so that can be
a hot cake Edge Computing boom of course
um so see when it comes to iot uh
internet of things okay U so so
basically with the iot devices uh the
the Computing happens at the edges
itself for fast Computing you can just
have the Computing done on the edge it
self correct rather than getting inside
the main Cloud correct so uh when it
when we talk about the chip level and
the uh like iot devices Computing so it
happens on the edges itself rather than
into the core Cloud so so so then it why
because the speed becomes very important
then and that's why the Computing can
happen on the edges and so the edge
Computing um is a boom so F Computing
comes into picture and yeah in fact a
lot of research is also going on in that
field so uh yes uh these is going to be
there right so that is what is changing
in the cloud plus devop space for 2024 I
would say yeah uh thank you so much Dr
purushotam for taking us through what's
changing here in the clouds plus Dev of
space uh I hope I'm audible yes yes yes
you're audible so we have talked about
the skills here we have talked about the
career paths you can take up in for in
Cloud plus devops so what exactly is
stopping you uh from becoming a cloud
computing and Ops expert here so uh I'll
just quickly launch a poll here uh this
is basically to understand what is the
biggest challenge you face when it comes
to taking a career in cloud and devops
and aspiring towards becoming an expert
in that field so you can see a quick
poll on your
screen uh this is a multiple choice
question poll so uh because there can be
multiple concerns right when it comes to
aspiring for a career like cloud and
devops
so as I'm speaking I see a lot of folks
have already started sharing their
responses for the poll here so that's
great uh meanwhile I just give 10
seconds more for the poll
fooks
also uh we have started getting a lot of
your queries in the Q&A box and uh we
are eager to address all of your queries
and we'll be doing that uh towards the
end of the session uh or we'll try to
answer as many questions as possible as
well uh during the session as well so
please just have a little patience uh in
case your questions is not answered and
we will address them swiftly so I think
I see most of the folks have already
responded for the whole here so what
exactly is stopping you from becoming a
cloud devops expert or taking up a
career in cloud and devops so uh last 5
Seconds B for the folks who are still
thinking about it so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and also share the
results with you folks so as we can see
uh that we have gotten
57% of the responses for I wouldn't get
the Practical exposure I need to become
ready and 31% for I can't find a program
with a fully comprehensive curriculum
26% votes for my work schedule allow me
enough time for Learning and 177% votes
for I find it difficult to learn from
prerecorded videos so thank you so much
for sharing that with us you can if you
have any other concerns you can also let
us know in the chat or in the Q&A box uh
if this doesn't cover basic your concern
now let's talk about the uh program here
so the I Gatti's professional
certificate PR in cloud computing and
devops uh comes with the the
comprehensive industry aligned learning
path you get access to integrated labs
and projects for hands-on experience uh
you get also uh access to online virtual
classrooms with live in instructor
interaction the program duration for
this one is eight months and you can
basically completed by just giving a
week uh this basically makes it very
flexible uh to fit your schedule and
also uh the eligibility and the Bri sets
of the program I think someone asked
about if I will be eligible for this
program you know if basically
I don't have a degree or something that
I think I saw that question so just to
let you take you thees here so you uh
maybe from a non-programming background
uh it is not necessary it's definitely a
plus if you are and uh you need to have
a high school diploma or equivalent uh
and at least uh at least 18 years of age
uh you don't have to have a work
experience here that is not required uh
so in case uh you are a fresher or you
basically are currently studying you're
totally eligible for this program with
which I saw a lot of you folks so that's
interesting so now let's talk about how
this program builds your Cloud plus
devop skills step by step and also Dr
purushotam will be taking them through
the learning environment of the program
as well uh in the upcoming slides uh Al
to show them what exactly uh the things
we are talking about how they can find
them in the learning environment as
well
yeah right uh so see basically um how
the program builds your Cloud plus
devops uh skill
step by step so see when you join this
program so initially you will go through
an induction session for um cloud
computing uh boot camp okay um so that
would be an introductory session and
once you do that then uh you would be
studying AWS Cloud fundamentals
okay uh so that in that you will uh
you'll learn about the fundamentals of
AWS okay um then uh designing
applications and architecture in AWS so
so you will be learning on on uh like
architecting in AWS correct uh that is
AWS architect associate and then uh you
will move to so see it's like uh
introductory session then fundamentals
on AWS then architect uh course on AWS
and then you go to Azure learn on the
fundamentals of azure Cloud platform
okay and uh then of course uh you would
be uh implementing uh managing and
monitoring on Azure environment okay
so basically learning on Azure platform
uh the monitoring and how would you
implement the services and manage them
and then finally the architect uh course
on Azure that is designing
infrastructure Solutions on Azure and
once you do that guys uh then um after
that you will have the cloud computing
boot camp Capstone project so in the
Capstone project it would be like uh you
would be having a project which would uh
have uh which would be a real uh real
world project uh that would include the
services of AWS and Azure both the
multicloud services and that would be uh
a project that would uh be a kind of a
realtime project okay and then a real
world project that you would be doing in
uh in the uh Capstone project correct so
that is what um the path would go
through and once you do that then of
course you would be uh awarded uh the uh
IAT goart certificate for uh this
particular program and uh of course
there are electives as you can see on
the slide so apart from these courses
that I have talked of right now which
are the compulsory courses that you have
to go through in order to clear this
program uh apart from these courses uh
you also have the option of taking these
elective courses now these elective
courses are not compulsory ones but then
you can opt for them you can opt for one
or all of them and you can opt for one
or all of them at no additional cost
okay um so whatever is the cost of the
program in those you can opt for that
these electives as well which are the
IIT goart faculty uh Master Class okay
so faculty members from I goart will uh
be giving you the U their U expert
lectures which you can go through then
um Google Cloud platform architect
training Big Data on ews um uh if you're
into the data site devops on Azure uh
generative AI master class and many more
okay so that is what uh you will be
learning in this program okay yeah uh
thank you so much Dr for taking us to
the steps here how exactly this program
builds their uh skills step by step also
I think you already mentioned about the
electives so electives come as a part of
the program uh they are optional but we
don't charge anything extra for that it
is up to you if you want to take it
uh and as we move on as we we we cover a
lot of tools and platforms you'll be
learning in this program as well so as
you can see there are a lot of tools
which is on the basically in this slide
but there are many more which we cover
in this program so maybe Dr pusham we
can give them a little bit idea about a
few of the tools which major tools which
are basically very important for someone
who basically are aspiring for a cloud
and devel uh
career yeah sure uh so see basically uh
I mean these just few ticks but then uh
we would be learning a lot of tools so
when I talk about AWS so guys U you'll
be learning a lot of services like uh
ec2 which is nothing but uh the elastic
compute Cloud which is a service that
helps you to create the servers in uh in
the IAS mode that is infrastructure as a
service mode basically creating the
servers in Cloud on AWS is something
that you can do with ec2 service then
similar thing in Azure you can do with
virtual machines service in azure
um then if you want to create let's say
a no SQL database okay so you can do it
with Dynamo DB service in AWS and Cosmos
being in assure then um it' be learning
all of these and uh uh let's say if you
want to uh uh run maybe your web
application or maybe your uh application
in Cloud platform but then you don't
want to provision a server for that you
want to go with a serverless thing okay
so that you can just write a function
and let your code execute in it by just
writing the code um mean in the form of
a function and let the servers whatever
required would be uh provisioned back
off the scene by the provider itself so
you don't have to provision the servers
so if you want to do something like that
well you can make use of AWS Lambda
which is a serverless uh service in ews
correct uh similar thing in Azure you
have got function apps in Azure correct
and then of course apart from that U
Amazon S3 uh which is there to to uh
store the object based data in AWS okay
and similar thing you can do it in
assure with blog blobs in assure okay um
then uh you have container service in
Azure with the name Azure container
service in AWS again you have it with
the name uh ECS elastic container
service and of course in Azure you have
the orchestration of containers with
kubernetes service that is eks azure
kubernetes service and in ews it is with
the name eks elastic kubernetes service
so uh yeah those also you'll be studying
of course uh should be studying then uh
yeah so and aure resource manager would
be there to manage the resources so uh
and a lot of resources like I mean lot
of services you'll be studying DNS
service uh the the the the the uh
networks like uh vpc's virtual private
Cloud networking service in AWS vets
virtual networks in aure
okay um DNS service databases storage
spaces um and whatnot I mean application
services like sqs SNS and stuff so all
these are some tools uh that you would
be studying so there are many more okay
just have given you a gist of
few uh thank you so much Dr P for taking
us to the tools and platforms you'll be
covering in this program and many more
we'll be talking more about that uh so
before we move on and talk more about
what this program covers and also
address all of your queries which we
have gotten a lot of interesting
questions in the Q&A box here we'll be
doing that pretty soon so last few
minutes to put on your questions in the
Q&A box meanwhile uh let us take you
through the live tour of the learning
environment of I bhati's Cloud plus
devops program so I think uh let me also
just check the options here the for
sharing yeah I think you be able to
share your screen Dr uh yeah okay right
so uh I'll just share my
screen I hope uh my screen is
visible uh yeah it's visible uh please
do let us know folks on the chat here if
it's visible for
you you can just reply yes on the chat
if it's visible yeah yeah so guys you
will see in the program you will see the
different courses and um if you'll get
into any of the course well I'll just
give you the um
uh know how of the learning environment
so if you get into any of the course uh
you will uh you can see here on my
screen that there is self- learning uh
section now this uh sorry uh one second
yeah so this self- learning section uh
will have uh the pre-recorded videos of
some good trainer that are already
available so in every course you will
see um in all the compulsory courses
you'll see this uh self- learning
section in which you will see thee
pre-recorded sessions of some good
trainer already there in all the courses
you'll see this then there's a live
classes tab now in the live classes tab
what you will see is the lecture
recordings lecture recordings of your
live classes okay so whatever the live
classes that you'll be going through uh
there'll be lecture recordings of that
those classes that would be available in
the live classes tab uh if you have done
some past classes so those would be
there um in your my classes uh this
course class uh I mean uh the uh lecture
recordings would be there so you can
revisit them you can always listen them
again and again if you wish to correct
um so that if you have missed some
portion or you want to revisit some
portion you can always do that okay uh
plus then uh in the assessment section
you can uh I mean you'll be able to see
the assignments plus the projects
related to the course okay uh the
problem statement so that can be taken
up uh at least one of the projects of
every course can be taken up can be
mentored by the instructor uh during the
live class and then in the reference
materials you will find the ebooks and
the data files um plus apart from that
whatever the trainer wants to share with
you the material so they can always
share that with you on the community
link as well correct um so here also
you'll have access to the standard
content okay then um other than that uh
you can have access to the practice Labs
uh so in the practice Labs uh you can
have the access to the labs which you
can launch from here okay uh since this
is a AWS course so this this uh when I
say launch lab so it would launch the
AWS lab okay and so so so the point is
you don't need to I mean you can always
create a AWS free tier account your
personal free tier account but then if
you join our course here then um even if
you don't have the AWS fre tier account
well that's not a problem because from
these Labs uh which are provided by
simply learn you can always access the
lab environment the sendbox environment
where in the lab would be available to
you for few hours um and then
uh and then uh you can just do your
stuff there and after those few hours
are over you can again launch the lab
okay so you all the labs can be done
through the sendbox environment that is
provided by simply learn then um of
course the certification so once you
once you do this course like once you
satisfy the criteria like you attend the
live classes all the self- learning
videos plus the project maybe so then
you'll be able to unlock your
certificate okay from here okay so then
certificate from here and and the way
I've told you uh uh for for for the AWS
course likewise you will see this kind
of an LMS environment for all the
different courses correct and of course
uh then um you will have the similar
kind of an environment for your Capstone
project as well correct so uh that would
be there so all uh such things would be
there and of course the elective tabs
would also be there okay wherein you
will find the as I told you about the uh
courses which are the elective courses
you can see it in the elective courses
also correct so that's how it goes about
and then there's a help section um if
you have any queries uh you can just get
into the help section and then um we
have a 24x7 support so um your queries
can be sorted out there correct uh so
that is there plus uh you can have
access to the community link so uh in
the community Forum um like you can be
connected with your peers the other
learners plus the instructor plus the um
plus the support team and then uh uh
even the instructor can upload the
materials extra materials whichever he
or she wants to share with you in the
community Forum so that is a great Tool
uh so that way you can get uh stay
connected with your peers and this uh
team as well uh apart from that the
instructor can share the uh additional
uh course contents whatever he or she
wishes to in the community Forum okay uh
so that's there yeah so that's there
yeah so I think this is yeah in shot
about the LMS and uh of course uh uh
there is this my resources section that
I think you can access in which the
webinars like uh this what we are having
it today and plus the other webinars you
can have access to and you can always uh
visit them and learn from that as well
yeah yes thank you so much Dr purushotam
for taking us to the life tour of
learning environment of itst cloud plus
theop program and let me share back my
screen as
well uh so as we move on uh the Capstone
projects which we talked about earlier
which you get to add to your portfolio
which you can showcase to your future
employees uh some for especially for
someone who has no experience in cloud
or devops uh the Capstone projects you
can choose from in this program uh helps
you showcase your true experience and
mimic real life business scenarios
uh which you can showcase uh basically
to your future employees and as I
mentioned that you get to work on one
project out of several domains and uh
where you can solve real business uh
real world business requirements with
Hands-On U virtual apps and uh they
basically provide rigorous examples as
well so let's talk about the industry
based projects handsome projects which
you can basically add to your portfolio
through this program uh the first one
here being deploying a multi-time web
app using Amazon sqs deployment of a
multicloud app the second one and the
third one is your and AWS connection
architecture through VPC so these are
some interesting hands on projects which
you can add to your portfolio and I can
assure you that Dr purushotam makes it
pretty interesting he when he basically
does this uh project demonstration and
takes you through a much more detailed
uh you know experience of this these
projects which you get to work on um
also we have global leaders as program
advisers Dr gor of sedi who basically is
the associate professor and uh of Triple
E and principal investigator for our
TripIt Academy here they basically make
sure that simply learn is delivering as
per standards of I guati and uh we also
provide job assess Services by Talent
Inc so Talent Inc is our partner here uh
where you get access to premium resume
rabbit uh job portal resume review and
rewrite service and also one-on-one
interview Service as well as basically
you are basically getting done with the
program and trying to get out there and
work on your resume and also prepar for
interview that is equally important that
is something talting provides and you
have access to it as well uh even 6
months after the program so now U as we
promised that we'll be taking a lot of
your questions from the Q&A box and we
see a lot of questions there in the Q&A
box uh let let us take maybe few
questions before we move ahead uh with
the program so as as we can see that uh
Vince ra has asked from development
background uh can we move to Cloud
native
developer Dr
P can we move to Cloud native I'll just
put put down that question for you on
the chat because uh we have a lot of
questions there it be hard to find so
yeah yeah okay no problems yeah uh can
we move to uh Cloud native developer
from development background yeah of
course you can uh see because if you are
a develop if you are into the
development background so it's it's
really easy to get into uh the cloud
native developer because uh the point is
if you want to be a developer on the
cloud platform let's say AWS developer
associate or Azure developer associate
is at204 so uh you need uh the uh uh a a
good good amount of coding experience a
good amount of coding knowledge I would
say okay and if you already have that
then it's it's always a good thing I
mean and it's always becomes easier to
get into that role because then um see
if you want to get into the Azure side
um well um then uh you should be good on
uh maybe net Services okay net uh coding
and if you want to be into AWS then
probably Java would be a preferred
option okay and if you are into it then
it becomes easier to get into uh these
roles uh the developer roles because you
come to know that how you can actually
deploy your code onto the cloud
platforms and which Services you can use
like web apps in Azure or um stuff like
that correct uh like elastic bean stock
in AWS which can be used for hosting
your uh web applications in AWS yeah so
yes you can pretty easily yeah I hope
that answers your question uh we are not
able to make out name from your email ID
but yeah R is what I can see and uh
you've gotten one more question from uh
again like himar I'm not able to make
out the name but I think I'll just share
that question with you once again on the
chat here so for you to have a detailed
look so uh that I also want to know
about the salaries in case I'm being
paid 18 lakhs in my domain with five
years of experience is it good to shift
to cloud computing as a fresher can I
expect equal or more salary than what
I'm getting paid now I know Dr P we
cannot exactly answer about the salary
part but maybe about the career
transformation in terms of salaries like
how does it impact as well yeah so um as
rightly said by Rasha so exactly
salaries you cannot talk of but then
yeah if you are a fresher into cloud and
if you just move to Cloud platform uh
without having any role of what you're
doing right now then of course salary we
cannot talk off or it can be lesser also
but then if you are into your current
role and then you add on with the cloud
uh being a fresher into Cloud then of
course you can expect more and and and
uh uh to tell you uh in Cloud platform
if you are let's say into the architect
role or like that so you can expect a
good good good salary like um uh I mean
uh you can expect even more than 25 uh
uh lakhs uh per and then one of my
friends as I told you he is he's he's a
senior Cloud architect and he's earning
more than 50 lakhs okay um so yeah so
then uh the the the point is that uh uh
to answer to your question which cannot
be answered purely but then uh fully
that uh but but if you are uh like if if
that cloud comes in uh being a fresher
in Cloud comes along with what you are
doing right now then of course there'll
be an hike in your salary but if it is
just a cloud pressure without the role
that you are doing right now then it can
be less than that also to start off with
in the cloud platform but going ahead it
would be uh it can uh go way ahead then
what you are running now also yeah yeah
agree with that uh Dr vam definitely the
growth is really high and we cannot
definitely put a number on the salaries
because it definitely differs but yeah I
think he has given example of what
exactly a senior CL about architect
earns we've gotten plenty more questions
uh but we'll be taking those in some
time uh we have talked about the skills
here we have talked about the career
paths will be trending in 2024 we have
talked about the projects you can add to
your portfolio through this program
we've talked about the tools and
platforms this uh program by it ghati
will be covering so now we would love to
know your interest in enrollment towards
the it Gatti's uh Cloud plus develops
program so you can see a quick poll in
your screen here so through this poll
you can share your interest towards
enrollment and we would love to know
your interest best uh in enrolling into
the IT ghati Cloud plus devops program
and uh as we have talked about how a
Capstone project uh basically through
this program can help showcase your uh
experience uh basically by mimicking
real life business scenarios through the
uh projects you get to choose from to
work on and also uh we have talked about
the industry based projects you get to
add to your portfolio through this
program as well so the IIs program is a
perfect program for someone aspiring
career toward W clouds plus devops and
also trying to start a career towards
cloud and devops so uh for folks I think
someone asked a question about I'm only
basically I'm not 18 years old yet uh
can I enroll into the program so I would
really suggest that in anyways the
upcoming cours are next year so in case
you're 17 you can definitely share your
interest towards enrollment and take up
a later goat uh next year of the program
of I bhati uh and and uh I see a lot
more questions coming in the Q&A box
we'll be addressing them pretty soon uh
Meanwhile we're just uh waiting for
folks to basically put on their interest
towards enrollment uh into the I gu's
Cloud plus devops program and uh I'll
just give 10 seconds more for the poll
here and I think an is asking is it
online uh so yes it is online uh and uh
the format is online you can attend the
session online it is pretty flexible in
terms of the videos also which you can
access to and also the live virtual
classroom which we have talked about you
get access to through I go program in
Cloud plus
devops uh I will be sharing the cost of
this program in the upcoming slides I
think someone asked that question uh as
well so I'll be sharing that and also
sharing with you the upcoming CS of uh
the program as well so once we done with
this board so I think last 5 Seconds
I'll GI for this poll here because I see
a lot of interest towards enrolment so
that's great uh but I think last few
seconds for the folks who are still
thinking about
it so would you like to enroll into the
IT ghati Cloud plus devops program folks
you can see a quick p on your screen you
can share your interest towards
enrollment through
that I'm as I'm speaking the polls are
still moving so I think I'll just give
five more seconds uh for folks who are
still thinking about it and also in the
upcoming slides I'll be shaking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program and also how exactly the
enrollment steps work and also I'll be
asking you basically when are you
planning to enroll I'm pretty sure uh
just a ball bar fig figure will help you
figure it out basically when exactly we
should reach out to you with admissions
off a letter and also in case you have
any questions about the program or any
questions regarding the program you can
let us know in the Q&A box because we'll
be picking up the questions from the Q&A
box pretty soon so I think last 5
Seconds uh for the poll here so are you
interested in enrolling into it goat's
Cloud plus devops program so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the poll thank you so
much folks uh for sharing a lot of
interest towards enrollment here into it
guti's program now for folks who have
already shared interest towards
enrollment into I guti's Cloud plus
devop program let me take you through
the enrollment steps here so uh there
are very three simple easy steps which
basically you need to follow in order to
enroll uh so once you basically get the
call from learning Consultants from
Simply learn so they basically will be
taking through these simple easy steps
you need to submit an application to us
at ask us at.net and once you have
submitted your application your
application will be going for review IID
gu will review your qualifications based
on the eligibility and the preer sites
which I've shared with you earlier and
the last step learning Consultants from
will be contacting you with an
admissions offer later uh and based on
the cohart you choose which I'll be
asking later so now I think someone
asked about the program fee and also the
enrollment uh schedule for this I gutis
program so the program fee for this is
uh 1ak
24,999 including taxes in rupees and
also uh someone asked if there are any
Emi options available so yes we do it is
for as low as
4,254 uh rupees per month and also uh
the upcoming cohorts for this I badis
program uh the classes start from 24th
Feb 2024 that is next year and the
induction for this program will start on
16th uh J Jan 2024 so in case you have
any more questions you can always reach
out to us at ask us at simple.net also
just to mention that we have limited
seats per C we only take 25 to 30 folks
per cohart in order to make sure you're
getting all the attention that is
required when you're taking of this
program so uh now we would love to know
how soon do you plan to enroll uh into
IAT ghati Cloud plus devops program you
can see a quick poll on your screen
which is launched so now this is for the
lot of you folks who actually shared
interest towards enrollment uh so this
is for the folks who have already shared
interest for enrolling into it goti
Cloud plus devops program uh so this is
something that will give us a very good
understanding when exactly do you plan
to enroll so the first option here as
you can see is immediately I've already
showed you the immediate upcoming cohort
here it starts in February and uh within
three months is the second uh second
option in case you're not planning to
join immediately but you would want to
join within three months third one is
within six months and the last one is
more than six months from now so I think
for folks who are still thinking about
it are not sure when to join but have
shared interest towards en norment I
would highly recommend to uh select the
last
options so I think I'll just give 5
seconds for the poll because I see folks
have already shared responses for the
poll here and we will be swiftly moving
towards the Q&A part of the session here
and we have a lot of questions and but
we'll try to take as many questions as
possible which we can take in the
limited time we
have uh I think uh VI has asked in the
Q&A box uh is it a one- year program no
it's it's the duration of this program
is eight months
viic I think uh I think I'll just give
last second seconds for the poll here
because most of the folks have share
responses for the poll the last 5
Seconds folks 5 4 3 2
1 okay let's move on to the Q&A part of
the session uh let me just quickly
browse to the questions you folks have
shared on the Q&A box I think we have
answered few of them during the
session uh so I think we have one
question
here Dr Pam I'll just put that on on
chat for you sure so we have one
question by wandana RoR here says that
can we use python in order to become
aure developer orn net is mandatory no
you can um you can use Python also to
become Azure developer but but but going
ahead with Azure I would I would suggest
you uh to learn um net uh because when
you will learn Azure developer you will
require net at some stage so um while
doing Azure developer also you can learn
it yeah so even but if you have python
um well you can start off with that see
because it at the end of the day if you
are from the development background um
it is not a big deal if you know one
programming language uh you can always
switch to other so basically the Logics
uh the programming logic is important if
you are good in that then you can always
switch between the programming language
it should not be a big deal
yeah uh thank you Dr Pam for answering
that uh Wana I hope that answers your
question please do let us know on the
chat or in the Q&A box if you have any
followup questions so uh I think we have
been questioned by Vince ra here uh
which says that how about missed
sessions uh will there will be a
repeated session you'll get the lecture
recordings isn't it that's what I shown
in the uh um LMS itself that the lecture
recordings would be available and uh you
can always go through it if you have
missed let's say some session because of
some a the other work okay you can
always get through that
yeah agree agree uh thank you so much
for answering the Dr
Pam okay I think just we have one more
question uh not able to make out the
name from the email ID web development
and devops any relation of or we use
devops in
web web development and devops any
relation or we use devops in web uh see
uh you can use devops in web and uh of
course now devops don't just limit it to
web itself it's like
devops is uh it it it it goes with your
complete uh cycle of your project isn't
it um when you talk about developing
your project uh okay so right from uh
writing the code to uh uh putting it
into the repository to uh compiling it
uh to to testing it to running it
deploying it uh so all of those steps
you can actually automate with devops
tools isn't it so it's just it's not
just limited to WAP uh development okay
um it is like U it's there uh in your
complete software uh engine ing life
cycle okay whatever the stages are there
those can be automated with the help of
devop tools yeah right from coding
testing uh deploying everything I mean
compilation of your code yeah yeah sure
I think one last question I think Dr P I
know we have exceeded few minutes uh
this is by Sol uh says that is python
knowledge required to make a successful
career in cloud and the Ops no not at
all not at all see if you want to be on
the developer side probably you will
require the programming language and
then also if it is not python um it is
not a must uh but but but yes if you
want to be like if you want to be into
the data science part then probably
python can help uh but if you are seeing
that you want to get into cloud and
devops and then um is python the most
important skill so not like that because
Cloud it's it's an ocean whatever you
have in your on premisis you have it in
the cloud there are so many letter in
fact if you're going with admin uh
associate course or architect so of
course the the point is that you don't
need uh the uh coding uh knowledge that
much
correct yeah yeah so yeah thank you so
much Dr pan for answering that uh I
think folks we will move on uh towards
the end of the session but before that
we would love to know from you uh do you
need assistance in enrolling into the
program because I did see a comment from
someone on the chat that basically I'm a
working professional and I have a very
busy schedule so uh we do help with that
so please don't worry you can just let
us know through this poll if you need
assistance in enrolling into I kar's
Cloud plus devops program so uh for
folks basically are meaning more
assistance in enrolling you can let us
know through this and learning
Consultants from Simply learn will make
sure that take you through much more
detailed walk through uh of the program
and also help you through the enrollment
steps of the program so I think I just
give 10 seconds for this sport uh
because I see folks have already started
sharing the responses for the poll here
uh and we are towards the end of the
program here so uh I would like to thank
Dr purushotam for taking the time out
for today's program preview of it Cloud
plus devops program and uh for and also
we would love to basically uh thank you
again once again and we would love to
know a little bit uh you know about
towards the end of the session now that
we are towards the end of the session we
did try answering all of the questions
as much as possible but we uh have
exceeded the time by few minutes and we
would love to end the session now so Dr
BR would like to say something to the
audience before we end the session yeah
so it was great to be with you guys and
thanks Rasha for inviting me for this uh
program and for this lecture um so um
heartfelt thanks to Simply learn and to
you Rasha and yeah so it's a great
program actually guys uh so one of the
top rated programs in the market um
because you'll get the kued IIT goart
certification also with that and let me
tell you uh simply learn um we strive
hard like I'm working as a lead trainer
here in simply learn so we strive hard
to uh make your experience uh better uh
than um uh whatever you have seen till
now uh and uh at the same time we strive
hard to give you headson experience um
uh the so that you are prepared uh for
certification at the same time uh you
are also prepared to work better in your
organizations you are prepared for uh
working uh in the realtime environment
correct in your organization so that's
the Crux of what we strive here in
simply learn correct so yeah it was
great to be with you guys and yeah
thanks a lot for being here thank you
Rasha thank you everyone yeah thank you
Dr Pam we would love to see in much more
upcoming sessions which we have lined up
uh with Dr purushotam here and also
folks who have shared interest towards
enrollment we would love to see you in
upcoming cohorts so thank you so much
once again thank you for being an
amazing audience here and uh we have
more sessions lined up for you uh which
you can check out by simply learn our
webinars which we have shown you earlier
thank you so much folks for joining
thank you please do let us know how did
you like this session you can let us
know in the chat or also in the post
webinar survey of basically popup which
you'll be getting once we end the
session so thank you so much thank you
thank
you